we but so is the man of my right my a
man who i love dearly i will be spending
way too much time with him on super
sunday right he joined us right here on
the rich eisen show pro football hall of
famer three-time champion courtesy of
trade trade zing joining us here michael
irvin good to see you michael man it's
great to see you great to be here rich i
mean richard district that's the real
news yes and and and also the we on the
set is the actual vince lombardi trophy
go ahead you can lift it and if you want
if you want michael you want to say
hello to an old friend right here
because yeah i have a few of these mine
don't look quite like this well this is
a really cool thing yeah here's the real
dilly willy i know this is what i think
i mean that's how we're rolling right
here i've held up three of these
holding these things up i've held up
three of them hey if some other body
some other people come in here and do
that then you get nervous because they
never held this thing
before but me
i've held this thing i've hold this
thing i've made love with this baby
is there is there anything that you can
save for airing uh repeat the
conversations that you've had or do you
want to have a conversation yeah that
baby
after we won that first one i did lay
with i laid with the right in my arms
like that
kissed her we went to sleep
just like that one night you know
because
you you dream about it all your life all
your life since a little kid you've been
dreaming about it
and when you finally win that thing man
it's an amazing amazing feeling
somebody's going to have that feeling
sunday yes sir it's their first super
bowl because then we don't have many
guys that have been here and certainly i
don't know any really that won a super
bowl so it'll be their first and the
first opportunity to win one man they
will have that feeling that that's so
crazy for me to know that no last night
when we were hanging on the set uh for
two hours super bowl opening night
together
you were making an analogy about
um your first
super bowl journey and what the bengals
are on right now right i thought to
myself i'm sitting there i'm like i
never thought i i i want to do the nfl
network thing forever and i know you too
and i want to do it forever with you i
never thought i would ever hear from you
you know the bengals are kind of
reminding me of my first
jersey my first super bowl journey
it kind of does though right and it's so
amazing they're a young team just like
we were in
and and everybody thought maybe they
were a year away you know and they were
going up against a a kansas city chiefs
team because we're going up against san
francisco was really a dominating team
so when you get over that hump you're
like man we got over that hump we get in
the super bowl they're practicing at
ucla let me tell you something and all
my years of being around football and
football
the practice we had at ucla
was the first perfect practice i had
ever been a part of it was a perfect
place i knew that wednesday i said oh
we're about to
we're going to spank that ass i knew it
wednesday i'm telling you that was not a
ball that hit the ground on wednesday i
would look what if cincinnati had one of
those kinds of practices
well you could run to vegas i'm telling
you that thing is serious if they had
that kind of practice because
and i said ucla man that's the last time
a super bowl was out here and we
dominated that game i don't think it'll
go that way for cincinnati but but this
is rich the year of the tiger you know
that everybody's been telling me this
year of the tiger the bingo the tiger
so it'd be interesting man it would be
mind-blowing
let me tell you something
i said this last year rich and i see it
this year i love this go for it there's
no way
that you if you are
the los angeles rams that you can let
this team come in here win this game
there's just no way because it's your
field it's yours it's just your home
field guys you
you you it's not you can't you can't
control your brain
you can control your actions but you
can't control your brain you can't tell
your brain to stop thinking oh use it
stop thinking that but your brain it
does what it does so so so now if i let
you beat me here
every time i come into this stadium i
have to remember that my brain i ca it
will go back to that so i have to beat
you now to make sure that i'm not living
with this for the rest of my life this
is your home stadium you cannot watch
other people catch confetti in your home
stadium all next year you will be
watching that during games that's all
you will see it's impossible i i would
be uh boy whoever has to block aaron
donald this is going to be great to
watch
or unless you're the one blocking aaron
donald right unless you're the one
watching that blocking
that person's family
that's going to be something you imagine
how he's going to play this game he's
already taste defeat in the super bowl
he's already tasted it so now he has
that bitter taste in his mouth and now
you're trying to give him a second
defeat in the super bowl he's going to
be considered one of the greatest
defensive players ever nobody he has
three three defensive players of the
year one of the greatest defensive
players ever with two super bowl losses
and lost in his own hometown i just
can't see it happening yeah 1990 was the
only other time a three-time
defensive player of the year played in
the super bowl lawrence taylor was the
last one to do that michael irvin here
on the rich eisenhower ot and you and
you wait a minute you're back up rich
yeah you just me can you understand how
great that is if you're aaron donald and
we mentioned with l
t man
i know i mean a game changer game
wrecker a wrecker of dreams i mean
however you want to put it and i even
told you last night or i told him last
night what we talk about here guys is
that when aaron donald
goes back to the hall of fame as a
15-year return yeah okay like he's in
year 15 of being a hall of famer yeah
the jacket is going to fit him perfectly
he's going to be one of those hall of
famers he looks like he could give you
about 15 20 seconds right on the spot
like that you know that about aaron
donald he's not going to let himself go
he's going to look great the gray will
look great on whatever beard he might
have right right like like mel blunt
when you when you see mel blunt return
to the hall it's like okay now i know
why they changed defenses and they
changed rules for this guy now i get it
that dude listen man
right i wish you people could see male
blood i was just standing next to him
he keeps going dude he keeps going he
doesn't stop i can't believe this was a
quarterback i mean i'd have gone back to
the sideline like coach now i'm not king
he wears his cowboy
and he's the nicest dude in the world
man but i can only imagine a little
receiver going out there and i was with
drew pierce and drew was that you told
me about the dream said man i used to
god damn
what i'm supposed to be over here
he's just he's a monster man and the
nicest dude in the world man the nicest
dude in the world michael irvin here on
the rich eisen show okay gents um i'm
gonna ask you now michael to repeat for
everybody here in this audience last
night we're on the air live and brady
says on his podcast what we talked about
at the top of our show
he drops
six days after announcing his retirement
never say never is what he says he's
already bored okay and and so
hold on a second michael irvin you have
the floor he's not bored he he's
learning see you have this idea this
figmentation in your imagination of what
retirement is going to be like and
that's all it is it's just a
figmentation in your magnet i'm gonna go
home baby to relax i'm gonna be able to
chill all around the house
man i was home for one week and my wife
would say hey take out the garbage what
let me take out the garbage
you want me to put these hands on
garbage i pulled you out together with
these heads
take out the garbage
so now tom tom is home for one week he's
been the boss in new england he's been
the boss in tampa for the last 20
something years and now he's home for
one week and he realizes he is not the
boss he is being bossed and my bishop
told me this he said when i retired son
i want to give you the best advice
because you know the divorce rate after
a player retires very high because you
know it just becomes a problem a guy's
trying to fit back into the house and
they want to run their house bishop told
me
work your way back into the house i said
what
yeah you got to work don't try to come
back and run the house you got to work
your way ease back into the house i pay
all them damn bills
that's my house the man in me comes up i
pay all the yeah yeah but the house been
running fine for the last 20 years
without you so you got to work your way
and that's what tom is dealing with he
has to work his way back into his own
home so that little figmentation and his
imagination how great it's going to be
it ain't really that great you know what
i mean because now you're being bossed
around and six days later tom came on
here he was like man five days with him
never say never
ain't no telling
and that's only five days
wait did we get to five weeks
or five months i i may not even get to
five months yeah it may not even get
into five months now that's the thing
that by the way
imagine being a host on live television
and having this since the immediate
first thought fantastic so um
how does it work now what if he's got to
touch the farv in him you know what i'm
saying and then all of a sudden
like what
obviously he's under contract to tampa
yes so so that's where he would go back
but first he got to have that rocket
that rocky conversation you know like
like he had with adrien you know
baby
i've never asked you to stop being a
woman you can't ask me to stop being a
man i need to get this out of me i need
to work this out of me so i can come
home and be the best me for you i just
need to play 10 more years baby
you know because it's real man this
thing is real man
leaving football is real it is i know it
is real well i can't get out of your
system but i i just found that i i i
found it you know amazing that he would
say that because now that does leave the
door if you're if you're bruce arians
and you hear that you're calling them
every day
if you're jason light you're calling
literally every day how's it going on uh
what's up buddy just checking in tom
yeah let's do it just check it in when
you're trying to catch him right after
they've had a little bit of an argument
and he's hot
you know what i'm saying you want to
touch it what's up
i don't know
what's going on man
he was working out last week at ucla
that's right he was here exactly he was
here there's something to this man it's
something to it let's just keep watching
this thing yeah you're too much
something to do i would love to see him
come out original come out like the
willies reed and save tampon late in the
season or something who's here we're
gonna have a quarterback you see what i
mean you never know because they still
have his rights
they're not giving that up to anybody
listen buddy your back signal you bring
gronky back right right around a three
and four start well
it was how insane would game day morning
be if that happened you kind of think
about it rich that's the that's that's
the only way he can he
there is no next level for tom brady no
there's the tom is at the highest level
there's no next level
but if he does that
say tampa starts out like one and four
at age 45. and then he comes back at 8
45 and he turned that thing around
giving playoff and then get them super
bowl that's your next level y'all kiss
my butt that's a national number right
now you're like oh my god this dude went
in the phone booth put on a cape and
came back and did that that's our next
level even for tom brady michael irvin
podcast available wherever you get your
podcasts uh michael and i and 19 others
by the way we counted the number of
people on the promo screen last night 21
of us 21 for eight and a half hour
edition if we add like i said last night
add one more then kurt will have his
dream of having an actual 11 on 11 drill
on our on our feet we could have that
too you know
all those dudes we got over there what's
up with trade zing what's going on
trade zing man and and this is the
platform and i'm learning more about it
rich i'm learning you know it's i want
to help some of these guys out here the
great story you know tom brady's going
to be fine
tom has enough stack and stacked in the
bank he's going to be fine but but when
i talk about leaving this game it's also
so difficult because you leave the game
and you you're dealing with the pain of
leaving the game but you're also dealing
with the pain
of your finances not being right and a
lot of things are coming out here you
guys see all these nfts and crypto and
all that i don't understand all of that
made a verse i don't understand all of
that so i'm trying to partner with
someone to teach me uh about all of that
and then help teach our guys some other
football players other guys about all of
these things so they can help
have a better way of helping their
families down the road it's about
helping my brothers all
my other brothers all my brothers out
here not just my sisters and brothers i
helped them all the time i wish i would
stop here helping them so much but
helping my other football brothers get
have a great soft landing
after life after football that's the
most important thing rich we're having a
pretty good afterlife i want more of
these guys to have that great afterlife
and not keep hearing these stories about
these financial issues that our guys are
having all right trade zing and uh
michael irvin thanks for coming here do
you want to say
uh parting words yeah it's my baby here
my baby she's going to have to go home
and sleep with somebody else this week
but that's okay you know this is my baby
yeah i'm happy for whoever gets to sleep
with it this time man that first super
bowl i promise y'all uh after the first
one rich i stayed in the locker room two
hours afterwards i just sat in the
last one to leave because i wanted to
taste that last drop of that super bowl
there is nothing like it look at that
right there and you don't even see
stadiums like that
that stands for the rose bowl it's
beautiful the san gabriel mountains is
as as the sun sets there's nothing like
it it was beautiful and it is a
different game so i'm telling all the
cincinnati beings all those guys that
that have never played you think it's
just another game it will not just be
another game you're going to feel that
moment you hit that field bar none ain't
no getting around it you just better be
ready to readjust refocus and get back
into the game love you irv thanks for
coming always love you see you guys see
you sunday see you sunday if not before
that's michael irvin forever too i know
you guys just watch the show go to sleep
wake up watch the show
we're gonna be right there it started
five seconds ago
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here